hey what's up guys my name is china
welcome back to the game engine
series so last time we started upon this
journey of creating a content browser
i'll have that video link up there
and today we're going to just continue
on now you guys in the comments
really loved the whole format of the
episode that i did last time which was
basically just like a
chill kind of coding session i guess and
so today i thought that i would continue
on in kind of the same spirit of
implementing this content browser
without really having
prepared much i have done this kind of
thing before and i understand how it
works but of course we're not going to
be copying and pasting code like we do
sometimes
and i'm just going to have a bit of a
chill coding session so without further
ado let's dive into the code and
take a look at where we left off so yeah
last time we basically had a very simple
file browser in the sense that we could
just see uh whatever our kind of assets
directory was so you can see we have
this asset path but once we have
projects
we will in fact be changing this to
actually like read the asset path from
the project configuration file uh but
otherwise we have a content browser
which reflects basically everything that
we have on disk inside this actual
directory
so like if we take a look at this like
directory
um you can see that we have uh you know
we have
these files and over here we also have
those files so everything uh
here should match what we have here now
the biggest problem
i think that's going on with this i mean
like it's not really a problem but
stylistically i guess it is
is we don't really have um uh you know
we don't really have
icons or something that you might expect
from like a real content browser
now what i do have uh and what i will do
actually is i will show you what
hazeldev looks like so hazeldev of
course is my kind of
uh like way more advanced development
version of hazel in fact i'm probably
gonna almost phase out the name
hazel for this engine just because i
know it's very confusing to have both
so we might call this like the game
engine series project maybe we'll even
rename it to something else actually
maybe calling it hazelnut isn't a bad
idea i know hazelnuts like the editor
name but if we pulled this hazelnut and
then hazel is
anyway i don't know we'll see too many
hazelnuts around but the point is
um and of course i'm in the middle of
like some refactoring so this is gonna
compile
okay so i finally have a building if we
take a look at the
bigger brother of the game engine series
hazel in fact this is more of
an overachieving younger brother i think
because
this has been around for less time
technically than the game engine series
anyway whatever the point is that um
over here we have we have our content
browser and you can see that we
obviously have kind of all of these
icons and everything's laid out
uh sort of like as columns i guess as
i'm going columns but then we have these
kind of square
buttons which are actually images we
have a label underneath it
and they're obviously quite differently
laid out to this
so what i want to do today is spend a
little bit of time kind of
changing the layout i guess of this to
more closely match what we have here
by the way like i want to quickly
mention that i
i'm honestly not sure how much time you
know and if it's worth me making videos
about doing all this i am gooey stuff
because
you know this is the kind of stuff like
i mean tweaking like the actual ui
this is the kind of stuff that can
literally take hours and i'm not sure
how interesting it is for you guys it
might be
it might make more sense to uh for me to
kind of do that offline and then
show you the results of what i've done
and then walk you through the code
let me know what you guys think about
that because what i'm about to do is
just play around with some i'm going to
like the rest of this video
probably and try and get like actual
icons in here
in a similar fashion to what we have
here which again might be
might be a little boring anyway let's
close uh the big brother hazel younger
brother over to
hazel and then we'll um get back into
our hazel see too many hazels anyway
so um how are we going to do something
like that well without digging too much
into the
i'm going code for the way that hazeldev
does it because actually i didn't even
write that that was all thanks to peter
um what i'm going to do is think about
the layout and obviously we don't have
that kind of side panel with all the
folders just yet either
so if we open up like paint or something
really kind of uh easy
to use easy to open is the word i'm
looking for if we draw ourselves what
we're looking at
inside that content browser what we have
is basically a folder followed by a
label
and we have a certain amount of these
but then eventually if there's too many
of them and i know i'm not running them
the right size
copy and paste existing ones actually
but if we
if we kind of exceed a certain uh
threshold
of like how many we can actually fit so
we need to do some calculating and see
how many we can fit
you know because obviously we can't fit
another one here because the width of
the panel just doesn't allow that
so what we do then is we drop down and
if there's still not enough room for
that then we obviously add a scroll bar
but again we shouldn't really need to
add a scroll bar because i'm going to
handle all that stuff for us but what we
need to do
is uh have the ability i guess to
advance to the next row if we want to
but otherwise this is all like a bunch
of kind of same line same line same line
along with um uh yeah so like i'm gooey
i mean same lines
along with maybe uh i'm not sure
actually how we want to render this i
might think about this quickly
um i know i'm gooey has this new kind of
table api in like the new
version i believe but i don't think
we've updated to that sub module yet
maybe that's worth doing
uh if anyone's used it let me know in
the comment section below but
i think what i'll do is i'll just do
this using what we've got here which as
far as i can tell
is just going to be a bunch of icons
first and foremost
um with like i'm going to simplify we'll
kind of render it
or maybe i should actually begin a
beginner group
like this shouldn't i so that way we can
kind of group them all together and then
advance to the next one
yeah we might do something like that and
then eventually like because
obviously we'll know the width of each
um one thing i didn't show is enhancer
you can also change the size of the icon
so you can make them really small
you'll fit more in or you can make them
really large which just makes the
thumbnails larger basically
um which is also something that maybe we
should consider but based on what i'm
seeing here
yet it might make sense to kind of
make it as like a group in i'm gui
because then i think we'll be able to
group these together and then
advance to here oops
to here instead of uh just going down
which is kind of how the default layout
in mindview works okay so with that in
mind let's take a look at
what we need to do so before i start
dragging in icons i'm going to kind of
almost
storyboard this with buttons because
buttons you can give an arbitrary size
to and it basically functions as like a
rectangle so i'm just going to block
everything out is basically the idea
i'm going to just switch to release mode
so stuff boots up a bit faster because
i'm not expecting to get many like
assets
or anything it's more about playing with
the layout and if i really wanted to
i could even like expose some parameters
by i'm going itself to change the
angular layout on the fly
that can sometimes help if you're really
tweaking stuff but i don't
end up doing that a lot of the time
because it's easier to just think about
it i think
and then kind of get it down but
whatever so what we'll do
is um for each of the things here we
obviously have a is direct
like if directory followed by um not a
directory so this is a file
so what i'll do is we have the file name
as a c string and that's fine
um in fact i guess we'll just get rid of
this stuff for now
and what i'll do is for direct it
doesn't matter if it's a directory or
not
the directory is just going to change
what the icon looks like so that's
actually maybe the first distinction
that's useful
to think about in our little paint
diagram it doesn't matter if something
is a folder like if i draw a
folder here um here is a folder
or folder like so we have like a folder
here
um it doesn't matter if this is a fold
if this is not a folder in a file
like in terms of the layout it looks the
same the only difference is going to be
like what image shows up okay what
thumbnail shows up here and obviously
the action of clicking on it
this should open the folder this should
not open the folder because it's not a
folder
so um that being said uh that means that
we should have any code
in kind of a more common place such as
up here so let's do like
if um and again i'm going to block this
out first i'm not even going to do any
ifs
i'll just do i am gooey button and we
can give it some kind of arbitrary size
so we'll give this a button we'll call
this um
i guess we might as well use the
filename c string here
and then we'll give it a size so the
size again is probably going to depend
on what size we
uh have our kind of zoom level i guess
set to
but we'll make it 256 by 256 for now
and then the the really kind of
important thing is obviously i want to
kind of do i'm going same line now
here's the other thing that i didn't
mention that actually would probably
make more sense instead of just
arbitrarily having a same line thing
um and again maybe i'll talk a little
bit more about how i'm gui works i'm by
no means an angry expert
but what same line does and the way i'm
gui usually works is you have something
called a cursor and this cursor
is not the mouse cursor it's just the
cursor of where the
the rendering where rendering the next
element like within the window is going
to take place
so we have a window this up here is like
zero zero it works
not like opengl with zero being here um
or like graphics programming usually but
in like kind of an application sense
where zero zero is usually the top left
so you have like a cursor and you have
an x and a y position that basically it
brings you over
to this to this spot over here and then
when you render something what happens
is
um this cursor advances to the next
place where you can draw something so
you've just drawn this 256
by 256 uh pixel folder and then you get
kind of advanced to the next
uh spot which will be like around over
here
now it obviously takes into account
things like uh you know alignment
padding
whatever um so there is a certain item
spacing
and that will add some kind of vertical
padding so you're not going to end up
here you'll probably end up a bit lower
than that
and then you can start drawing your next
one now what we have the ability to do
is call a function called same line
and what same line does you call imgui
same line after you've rendered your
element
what that does is it actually says okay
let's
roll back the cursor so not to here
because that would override the current
item
but to the next horizontal space so it
almost like undoes
the the y vertical advancement of that
cursor
you can also call i'm going set cursor
to manually set it to some place which
means you can do whatever calculating
you want
right you can use like the content
available region which is like how much
space you have available on the panel
minus like scroll bars and stuff and
then you can
uh well you do factor in padding factor
in your own font matrix and be like i
want my element to be rendered exactly
here and to be exactly the size
so i'm doing allows all of that which is
really flexible and we've had to use
that for some of the layouts
in um in the real hazel but
um we don't really need any of that
because one thing i forgot to mention
is that we can just use the concept of
columns
now what columns are kind of what you
maybe think of
uh would think columns are which is
basically just going to split
this whole i'm going renderable section
into a set amount of columns
and then if you want to go to the next
column you just call i'm going next
column
so we have what one two three four five
we have five columns here
we can define a certain size for them
otherwise they'll be all even evenly
spaced now evenly spacing
even spacing is actually what we want so
this works really well for us
um and then you know so basically what
we do is we say hey i'm gooey give me
five columns
um and that splits up the panel into
like five
areas and then we basically render
something and then we go next column
render something next column
next you kind of get the point and if we
obviously keep rendering within a column
it's a column
so we can easily just draw the folder
followed by drawing the
um text underneath it which is great and
then when we try and go next column but
we're already at the last column
then it obviously goes down to the next
row and we start again
at the end of all this we can basically
be like i'm gooey go back to one column
and then if we wanted to we could draw
like this status bar at the bottom which
i believe hazel dev has
so that will that basically tells you if
you click on something it will tell you
like the full path and
some other kind of status things so
that's kind of what i'm thinking we'll
use instead of trying to like do all of
these on like the same line
i think columns is actually a perfect
fit for this and again the new table api
is probably even better because it lets
you
do rows and probably a more ensure they
think again i haven't actually
looked at the new table api i'm just
assuming that it's a table because it's
called
the table api anyway
let's get on with this so what i'm going
to do is instead of all this same line
junk i'm going to say let's just say
that we want to have
five columns and again obviously we want
we need to respond to like the size
of the uh content browser panel but i'm
going to ignore that for now
so we'll say i'm gooey columns and um
let's do five right now if we i'm pretty
sure i'm not sure if it
works if it's only until the rest of the
window but i'm pretty sure
you need to set this back to one yeah so
it is for the current window this is the
nice thing about having i'm gui um
source code here you can easily see what
it does and i do this all the time and
in fact
we've got to fix a lot of things as well
and i'm good so it's always good this is
another
um kind of uh argument for why you
should definitely have
important source code inside your actual
project um if it's
for nothing else than reading that's
also important so we have the window
right and it's for a given window so we
get the current columns of the window
um so we probably don't really need to
[Music]
like end this if we don't want to but
i'll i still will put a
um if columns one here and obviously
we're not trying to do this
by the way in case it wasn't obvious by
my silly code here we're trying to do
this for the entire kind of thing so
maybe we'll have our back button and
then after the back button
which i'll talk about later we'll create
five columns and then we'll go back to
one column at the end and we can have
our
you know status bar whatever start
as far um but for now we'll just uh
have this here so what so what what um
what do we do here so we basically
say i'm glue button uh and then i guess
when we're done when we're sure we're
done well let's let's do our text right
so we'll do i'm gooey text and we'll do
the same thing and again this should be
below the button
and then finally at the end of this
we'll just say i'm going next column
and i think that by itself should
already kind of
look like maybe what we wanted to do
but let's see
i like these casual coding sessions
they're uh
they're nice because they're just chill
um okay so you can see what we've done
here now we do have dividers between the
columns which lets us adjust the size of
the columns i'm pretty sure we can just
disable that
and also 256 may have been a little big
but you can see my point
right we literally have exactly what we
wanted we have a content browser
a fairly large font here because that's
what i've done but it's got a button
um for everything and we obviously have
everything sorted i think in
alphabetical order here and we'll
probably want to well i don't know if we
want to i guess we do we probably want
to sort folders first like windows kind
of does it
just like mac os which just kind of
sorts alphabetically regardless if
something is a folder or not
um but uh because at the moment you can
see
it looks like it is just alphabetical it
doesn't matter if it's folder or not
um and then uh yeah i guess clicking on
it maybe double clicking on it should go
to the next
it should kind of go into that directory
but um the columns are all there now
these dividers let's see how we can get
rid of the dividers because
i don't want the columns to be resizable
now okay this might be a little
bit of a interesting thing to look at
because i actually have no idea how to
do this and instead of googling this i'm
going to just try and
see oh look currently working on the new
tables api to replace columns
um okay cool well i definitely should
probably have upgrades to that
we'll talk about the table at the end
maybe next week or next time
next week that's hopeful but maybe it'll
be even sooner maybe it'll even be
tomorrow
um probably not so um so uh
what's okay so columns obviously like
dividers and columns and stuff
i'm sure there's going to be some kind
of um
potentially like a okay so this font is
being resized here
that's kind of looks good and columns so
he's being resized no border so
it's being resized false effect um there
is being resized flag
ensures we preserve pre-resized columns
okay so it looks like so is being
resized
obviously gets set to true here if the
column
is being resized and if we do the drag
column
but i'm guessing that if this only works
is it flags and
no border is not set
so i think if we can set column flags
and actually there's a border there so
let's just say zero and then false
that might actually just be the solution
in which case that was very fast
i was assuming we'd have to look at more
code
i'm usually pretty straightforward well
yeah perfect we have no border
which means obviously there's nothing to
resize so that's exactly what we wanted
um and now we actually have the perfect
thing
now before we talk about the perfect
thing um
what's important is to actually
uh talk about how big everything is
because obviously like 256x56
is like a certain thumbnail size so
let's talk about
you know how we would work out how many
we should fit here
because the other problem is that if we
um make it too small like i just made it
128 by 128
then obviously if this content browser
is just really wide like this example
here
we have all this weird space and we
don't want that but then on the other
hand we don't really want to set the
size dynamically
we could definitely do that so we could
say that we have a fixed amount of
columns
it's always five columns and if you make
it really thin the columns become
smaller if you make it really large
the columns become bigger but that's not
usually what we want so if we again
take a look at the assets in here we've
got some textures here i know there's
only two
um which is a bit unfortunate we need
more assets and look at this
resize behavior anyway
um if we zoom in and out here right it
sets a
a like it it deliberately sets
a particular size for this thumbnail now
obviously if the image itself is smaller
you can see it does this weird area
thing
whatever but we have this like this size
that we've zoomed into
that is here if there's not enough space
it drops down
right so in other words we have a fixed
size for our thumbnails that can be this
big which is great
more will fit if it's able to but
otherwise
um it's going to run out of space and
then it's just going to look like this
right so it's all dependent on the
actual fixed size of
a thumbnail how much how much space does
each file or each directory actually
take up
now um again that means that the columns
are set dynamically and so that's what
we'll probably do so we'll have like
some kind of um
size indicator or like the way to resize
things that will just basically
uh you know set the um
what will that do that will set the
thumbnail size right
um but then this and how many columns we
can fit is going to be dependent on the
thumbnail size
now the thing is there's a there's a few
things that actually go into this
right so if i say i want my thumbnail
size to be 256x256 that's not exactly
going to be the size of each cell
because we also have to account for like
the padding that i'm going places but i
am fairly sure
we can ask you what the padding is
obviously and what the item spacing is
which might
be a better question to ask but i'm just
wondering if you can tell us
the size of a cell just without having
without us having to manually calculate
it because that would be kind of nice
but whatever so what we'll do is we'll
run it we'll use an i'm going function
called
get content region available i use this
quite a lot now there's another one
called available width
for some reason this one is has been
obsoleted
but it just returns get content region
available which
you know is not obsolete because i'm
assuming that's kind of
important um although it is bound to be
redesigned soon
so that's a bit weird but i guess we'll
use not the obsolete one but we'll just
use this which is the same thing
so um let's do like uh panel width or
something like that right
so this is going to tell us in pixels
how much space we actually have
and so if we know that we have a
particular thumbnail size
which again we'll say is 256 then we
could
you know we'll count we'll put padding
into this as well so we'll say that
maybe
our padding between elements should be
at least like i don't know man
like 16 pixels that might be too much um
and then
we'll say um so we have basically a
padding and a thumbnail size so i'll
make a little cell size thing
and that will be padding plus or
thumbnail size or two plus padding
so if that is the case if we have a cell
size which at the moment with these
current things is 272
uh pixels right so if we have 272 pixels
and then the panel width is like
i don't know a thousand pixels then
obviously what we can do
is just divide divide the two together
divide the two together
um if we divide panel width by 272
then uh you know let's just launch a
calculator
so 1000 divided by messing up
divided by 272 we can fit 3.6 cells
right which isn't that much
um but three again that's a pretty big
thumbnail size
so we have this many cells that we can
fit now 3.6 is a
fine number but we can't fit 0.6 of a
cell that's weird so we obviously have
to round down so this is just going to
be three
um and so basically what we can do is
just say int
column accounts is just going to be a
panel width
divided by cell size um and obviously if
we just
cast that to an end um after doing the
division
like this then uh
we now have our column counts that we
can feed into here
based on a thumbnail size of 256
right now then we can feed the thumbnail
size into here and we
already have a bit of a poor man's
layout um where this will
just i think this should just work um
now obviously you know these file name
strings might be too big
um i don't even know how it's gonna work
to be honest uh again it's going to
it's got it is going to in fact fill up
some kind of
um you know space as in like it's going
to
uh the columns are going to be evenly
spaced which is probably what we want
now the reason why i'm making this stuff
static is actually because i want to
kind of add sliders to it
um i don't know if i want to do that
here though let's do this instead
so we'll do oh no well i mean that's
let's not do that so
we'll have this stuff here but i will
when we have our kind of status bar i'm
going to add two things i'm going to add
a drag float
let's do a little slider float um this
is going to be our
thumbnail size this is very
just work in progress but this is what i
mean by you know using i'm going to test
i am gooey um it's really quite helpful
for that so let's go ahead and
hook in our what was this the thumbnail
size which is this
um again i'll make it from anywhere from
like
16 to 512 or something like that
it does not have to be a power of two
obviously and then we'll have another
slider float for the padding and we'll
have this from like zero
to 32 um and then this is going to be
our padding now keep in mind that
padding is very arbitrary this
has nothing to do with i'm gooey padding
it's literally just the size of the cell
so it's a bit weird um because we don't
even maybe i shouldn't have done this
um because it's not going to affect the
actual padding between items
um oh no sorry it is because thumbnail
size is what we fit into a button
but that's not cell size right so cell
size is different
so it is actually going to be slightly
different um but anyway
if we launch this that looks good
they're both closed right
then let's see what we get
i don't know why these compile times
feel so slow maybe it's just me
look at that we've already done it so
that seems to fit well
right so if i full screen this oh look
we fit way more
so um we've got our controls down the
bottom obviously but the point is if i
resize this
you can see how it works actually works
really well i feel like it just works
better than it does in hazel there
so maybe i need to have a lot of paint
on anyway um
i'm just kidding i'm sure he did a great
job uh
so we can change the thumbnail size
which obviously changes
a lot right and then i guess the problem
is that what if it's too small
then we're gonna probably round down to
zero so we're never going to be able to
do that
we can set a minimum size but for now we
can just say
if column count less than uh one then
we'll set it equal to one or we could do
some kind of like
min function or a max function i never
know which one because they're different
in different libraries but
um yeah we'll just make sure that we
kind of clamp that to one
and i mean looks pretty good to me so
that's that's the way that that works um
okay with the padding you can see what
that kind of does
so um you know if we have to guarantee
that there is a certain amount of
amount of space between each item like
this then it's not going to be able to
make it smaller than that so you can see
as soon as we
get below 28 pixels between elements
it's going to immediately
snap down to a new row and limit our
columns to three instead of four
so that's what padding does so if we
make it really tight zero
you'll see that it's actually possible
to have
no space basically between elements now
there will be space between elements
because again
i am gooey's item spacing and padding we
haven't touched that that's in the i'm
gui style and we could touch that but
we're not
this padding is an artificial padding
that we're just doing for our layout
so if i set this up then you can see
that you know if it has to be 16 pixels
then
it means that as soon as it falls below
that it makes a new row
but that's pretty much it and then
obviously thumbnail size can be
absolutely any value
um and it will uh you know resize
accordingly
now if it's too small for text then that
also is probably something you don't
want
but um i think you know what should we
settle for here
like i guess 128 is probably a decent
size right because that's that big
i mean you can see we don't fit certain
things but we're not actually going to
have text here that's kind of temporary
all right we're about half an hour in so
let's see what else we can do
like i don't give you guys these videos
enough so i'm gonna
i'm going to make this episode a bit
longer so um
that all looks good to me i feel like
there was something else i was
considering oh yeah 128 so we'll make
this like 128 right um and then
16 padding i guess is like it looks fine
keep in mind the text size that i'm
using is quite a bit
like exaggerated um if i probably
shouldn't push that to the branch but
um all of this by the way is in a
content browser branch so if you go to
because i know that i think the last
time i didn't push it or something
but if you go to the hazel repository
which is always linked in the
description of these videos there's a
branch here called content browser which
really
is now sticking um and uh this is what
um
two months ago wait
did that push i don't know so the
content okay that didn't mean i know
that's it
no i didn't mind
uh this now was the previous episode
right and then i'm gonna also um push
like the updated changes from today as
well so you can take a look at it there
but just know that it's not in the
master branch because it's very much
work in progress and i don't want
everyone to just see that
but i might i might do something with
the um
with the font ah so that it's not always
because it is going to be super big for
you guys at least in this branch but
anyway
so where are we now uh let's make the
buttons work
um so double clicks how do double clicks
work
so i know there's some kind of
yeah there's just some is now double
clicked um
okay what is the mouse button
just an inch
so it'll just be this so
if we double click the left mouse button
um so
this is going to be like i guess we can
probably just do something like that
right
so because if we will we wanted to
double click on this like yes
so um and this is obviously if it's a
directory so
okay so okay all right so we can
probably no we don't necessarily need to
we can also double click on assets i
guess that should just open them in like
the
hazel asset editor or something um
because that is also what doesn't
have so uh let's just basically
wipe out this code um almost
so let's we'll put that it back um
i will put this here
okay that was that's fine
so um so if in fact we do double click
on this
um then if it's a directory we want to
navigate to the directory
so we'll do that and that's actually
probably all we'll do for now because we
can't open files just yet
otherwise we need to obviously open the
file so this basically gets rid of this
um let's give that a shot so now
hopefully we can browse
our directories like we used in the past
but this time we double click
okay so that didn't work um
okay so button that wouldn't button be
uh
it's possible that this is not
actually that's weird i mean i would
have i've never done i think i've ever
tried this before
but
but surely that would have worked
so now this is just going to work on
single click but i'm just curious
why that didn't work because it should
have
we we did click on the button
oh wow why do we get so many of those
events oh we're in a for loop
right yeah because it because it'll be
um it'll be true for the entire frame
right wait was i double clicking on a
i wasn't doubling was i sorry on a
on a file was i that's a bit of a clown
move
and i'm not usually known for my client
no i'm kidding i'm exactly
no i wasn't okay just just sanity check
but why
then why if it's true at the beginning
of
if it's true at the beginning of the
frame then why on earth would that be
not
does it not count as a double click if
it's on an element no surely it does
right
mouse double
click
so solving some problems here live
um dc double click
so that's what i wanted to know
how strange okay so
here's my double click on this
okay so it is a double click
but it doesn't
does the little thing not registered
before the button registers
this is very odd
i'm i mean i guess that's what's
happening
um
i don't understand why that would be the
case
so if mouse double click
um let's do
dc else not
not dc so this is only gonna obviously
um
this is obviously going to only print if
we actually double click
on the button but that's
very strange okay so that's your print
not dc
yeah so it never prints dc
huh
that's so strange why is that the case
let's read a bit about this another
thing i might try
is
i mean i don't know but
what if
we just stick this here so we do it
within the button
i mean i don't really see how that would
make a difference
but i guess if the nah that's always not
double tapes
all right well i'm not sure why that's
not working to be honest but
let's do let's move this to a bit of a
different strategy so what i can do
instead
is i can just do a normal button that
isn't clickable
but i can say if
if the mouse uh is double clicked while
the
item is hovered right so i am gooey
um is item covered
and double click
right so that's gonna be kind of like
the double click action filter specific
last item that was like if it's harvard
which of course
so that that also does much okay let's
it probably helps to remove the end
pulse
um but yeah that should probably work
now
yeah there we go okay so now we can
double click
not single click but we can double click
and we'll go into that
specific folder all right a little bit
weird why it wasn't working i'm not sure
why maybe someone can tell me in the
comments i'm sure it's just like a
eventful
thing with anything but okay so
um the final thing that i want to do is
have like directory icons right so at
the moment we're just doing these as
buttons but it's actually pretty easy to
use
image buttons instead there's no real
difference between these two
so instead of a file name we can just
provide an actual texture id which of
course we could load up here when we
create the content browser panel now
again technically you
probably want some kind of like
hazelnuts or like
editor asset manager that's not really
the asset manager for the game
but for the editor it has all the editor
resources in it
um so that's kind of what we want and in
fact this is a good time
to probably also quickly mention that we
should
separate our assets from
uh from not our assets so as in the game
assets from
these things called resources so
hazeldev has like
basically resources and then the assets
are not
in there the assets are
inside the project directory which could
be like in a you know in a completely
different place in your computer
obviously it doesn't have to be within
the actual hazel project because you
know hazel's the engine but you might
want to open a project that is like
you know somewhere else in your computer
because that's normal but resources
are like assets that are specifically
for the editor and not like i don't want
to call them
assets because assets are game assets so
there's a bit of a distinction there
right
and so what i want to do is um
basically inside here you know let's
i'm just going to i'm just going to copy
the icon that we have
inside uh
hazel dev that's why
we make a new one so it's called folder
let's make it
called directory icon and let's
make it right so it looks like this
um it's very difficult to see on a white
background
because of course it's meant to be
enjoyed i don't know why it's clicked
black um that's uh yeah this whole
windows explorer
content browser panel is a bit flawed
but anyway um that's what it looks like
right
so how do we load that well how do we
load any texture
i actually don't know the answer to that
probably texture 2d create
or something like that i don't know my
own api
because i don't know if it's the same as
little dev or not uh yes it's actually
2d and then create with a path should
work
so again you probably don't want to do
this every time you create the content
browser panel which by the way is not
going to be often at all it's going to
happen like every time you maybe
load a different project with a
different asset path or
i don't know close the panel and open it
again but even in that case it shouldn't
probably won't create a new one you'll
just not show it
so it's probably not that big of a deal
but resources icons
directory icon dot png
and you know what i'm going to be super
organized because like based on like how
hazel dev is going i know
that there are going to be so many icons
and stuff so i'll call this content
browser
right and i'll put that in there so we
have this specifically in the content
browser panel
um kind of in the content browser
directory
right and that's it so let's include
texture
2d which is in like hazel renderer
texture.h probably
yep um and then
sure uh we'll make wrapped texture i
should do this to the pedophile
uh res uh sorry wrap texture to dm
um uh directory icon
and we'll set it here
all right cool so uh image button
is now going to do directory icon get
renderer id
and uh what else do we need
a size which we have and i think that's
it we might need to flip this
we will actually i'll just do that
preemptively so we'll do
uh one of the first few days zero zero
so we'll do zero one and then
one zero now why is this
um upset that's a um 32t and it wants an
iron picture id
well they're actually the same thing i
believe so let's do that
um yeah one thing i want to mention is
that the cool thing about image button
is
you can also tint it so you can set a
background color just in case there is
none so by default it's like a zero
alpha as well so
the transparent part of the image will
just be transparent to the power
background
but then you can also set a tint color
which is white obviously so it
multiplies with that color
so if you wanted to make if you wanted
to gray something out you can definitely
do that
or you can change the color based on
anything really
so in that sense it's actually pretty
pretty useful okay and with that in mind
let's give that a run
and we should just see the image button
now obviously this goes without saying
but
uh make sure your icon is a decent kind
of resolution
right so i don't actually know how big
this
is 512 right so we can have actually
that's
the maximum thumbnail size that we
coincidentally set so that's kind of
nice
um but if we open this now you can see
we have it okay so it doesn't really
look
transparent to me
uh maybe it's not transparent because
that
that is not transparent so i'm not sure
we might have to inspect that file
again um but you can see that we now
have folder icons now they show up
everywhere
because we didn't really distinguish
between you know
files and folders uh should we use some
kind of
uh different icons for maybe
a file so let's see what else i have
so we also have this kind of file icon
which looks like that
so um i'm gonna just bring that up and
we'll make a
file icon and this will be file icon
and then duplicate this i guess
file icon
yeah so now this this actually kind of
does matter if it's the directory or not
so um because we'll get the the
kind of uh what will probably happen in
the future anyways i'm not gonna spend
too much time writing this is we
actually have to get the extension of
the file
to see what type it is so if it's a png
we might display like a
thumbnail of it if it's a an fbx file we
might just play like a rendered model or
some kind of fbx logo or something
so obviously it's going to matter it's
not like we have just files and just
folder icons
so because of that um you know uh
it's fine to not kind of
worry too much about the icon here um so
what i'll do is
for now i'll just say that if it is a
uh so we'll change this here if it's a
directory we'll make it the directory
icon otherwise we'll make the file icon
so pretty simple i'm actually really
curious why
it's not transparent because it
definitely seems like
like it should be but anyway okay so
there we go um
uh you can see the channel.txt is in
fact you know it's a um
file icon and if we're going to like
fonts open sans we can see all the
opensound stuff
now this text is very big i realize that
um that's probably one thing we want to
do actually is do some kind of
uh wrapping on the text or at least not
not even rapping but maybe like i mean
like what does windows explorer do i
mean i guess
if it's like uh let's just create
a super long name okay so we can
actually
wrap it but again it's just so much
smaller than this that it's not a big
deal
um i'm gonna be has like a text wrapped
thing
so let's maybe give that a go
uh but otherwise you know this is again
all this kind of aesthetical stuff that
you can spend
days on because tweaking everything so
what happens if we open
uh what are we opening this yeah so you
can see now how it kind of wraps it but
again you might not want to do this
um but i just want to like reiterate
that obviously this is a problem with
the current
text size like or if you have huge file
names but
i just mean it might not necessarily
need to be a problem that we spend
too much time fixing so like this font
stuff
again it's times two at the moment but
if i get rid of the times two
then it should be like it should
probably look a lot nicer
so you can see that there now we're also
not centering it so i might
want to do that but uh you know if we go
back to like fonts and open sans you
know this is much less of a problem
and this is obviously starting to look
exactly the same as it does in windows
explorer
minus the whole text not being kind of
you know censored
um but that's pretty much it anyway um
that's probably the end of this video
i'm not you're not exactly sure why the
background is not
like that it might be the actual assets
maybe something that we'll take a look
at next time
as well as perhaps the new table api but
this is obviously starting to look like
a content browser that looks just a lot
nicer
uh and that's probably too small for a
minimum size but
yeah we now have a kind of
the back button is sour spirit place but
we now have a pretty nice
kind of um uh content browser that we
can actually
navigate and uh very soon we'll be able
to actually drag in
things from here into like you know a
texture slot maybe that's something
we'll do next time
anyway if you guys enjoyed the video if
you did please don't forget to hit the
like button
pretty long video let me know what you
thought of this format again everything
was kind of live and
uh i really enjoyed it to be honest i
think
i think if i kept it this woman up i
probably would make videos more often
for this series but again that's that's
not because um you know
that's not to say that that's what i
should do and i don't want you guys to
like necessarily jump at that
opportunity
um because i know that a lot of you
probably will because uh but i i
generally do want some feedback
to know like this content is a little
bit more in line with what you were
expecting from this series because at
this point like
you know the series doesn't really
belong to me anymore the series is for
you guys like i make this series for you
and for kind of you know teaching you
and um
uh i don't know entertaining you
potentially i know
some people watch this for fun which is
very interesting to me
but anyway um the point is that let me
know what you think of these kinds of
videos don't forget you can help support
by going to patreon.com
you'll get access to the hazel dev
source code that you saw earlier
um while i was showing hazel dev earlier
all that stuff is all available for you
guys to check out so if you want to help
support
this series and everything that i'm
doing here on youtube
um then you can of course go there and
uh you'll get to the source code as well
as a few other kind of perks but anyway
thank you guys for watching i will see
you next time
[Music]
you